the greatest
discovery in 3,000 years will uncover
the origin of a secret power and lead
history's greatest heroes where they've
never gone before you are speaking with
a pharaoh kiss my staff oh uh is it okay
if I don't now you and I both know
there's something magical to me see
Sun Goes Down tablet starts to glow
everything comes to life
this Christmas yes we look similar da da
no no I'm not your Dada
no touch aah stop it the magic is
running out there's nothing wrong with a
tablet we shall all be dead by Sunrise
Hun's don't hyperventilate honey
negative but their greatest adventure
these guys depend on me pests just begun
we have to go to London to figure this
out
hello welcome to the British Museum he's
be wicked being a security guard in
America with your gun with a silencer
with your ninja swords that's not even a
little bit true looks cut up I want you
to see here and make sure nobody comes
in or out
okay sir lancelot at your service
Theodore Roosevelt President of the
United States of America I have no idea
what that means
aren't you take a picture last longer
Night at the Museum secret of the tomb
where the heck are we
Pompeii
we must never speak of what happened
here today come on that wasn't necessary